i asked on twitter a little twitter poll
uh have any of you
actually lied to the pollsters about
your support for trump
hundreds of people said yes and they
weren't saying
we might lie or we we think we'll do it
in the future
they said we have this year
it's locals week here on the reuben
report and i'm doing a series of mini
interviews with creators on why they
decided to become less reliant on big
tech
and instead own their content community
and livelihood with locals.com
joining me today is the creator of the
legendary dilbert comic strip as well as
a best-selling author and guy who really
really loves coffee scott adams welcome
back to the reuben report
thanks steve thanks for having me how
much coffee do you drink a day
i always think you're just drinking
coffee constantly basically
you know christine and my wife gave me a
new trick where i only do half
coffee and half hot water and
instead of coffee it's like a coffee
flavored beverage that you can drink
more of it
so that's my current trick for doubling
my output i think that's a little bit
like an americano right
isn't that when you go to europe and you
drink an americano it's just coffee and
they just add water to it i think maybe
you know i don't know my coffees but i'm
going to say yes
i'm just going to say yes to that you
got very long island there when you said
coffee
your coffee you don't know your coffee
well i'm upstate new york so we
we we drink coffee and we go up on the
roof and
down down by the creek all right we go
swimming in the creek well i'm gonna
send you one of these locals coffee mugs
we've got one uh but before we get into
locals and you've absolutely just
crushed it on there um i wanted to talk
about
something separate altogether which is
that because we live in this strange
time
where it seems no one can make sense of
anything you're one of the people on a
very
short list i can probably do it on one
hand
people who i think are actually making
some sense
did you ever think you were going to be
a sense maker i mean that's partly what
being a comic guy is you're you're
making little quips and you're trying to
make sense of the world but do you ever
think it was going to be this level of
it
you know you're asking me the most
embarrassing question you possibly could
because the answer is yes
you're supposed to be humble here yeah i
know the the
the answer is yes in my whole life
actually so um i always had an image
that someday i didn't know what path i
would take
but then i would be doing something in
public in which i would be explaining
things to people who needed a little
help having things explained
so you know it's it's amazing that it
ended up the way it ended up
because the way i got here could not
have been predicted in any way
but yes the answer is i did see my
future exactly like this
yeah are you shocked though to see that
the general systems of sense making our
our institutions the media the rest of
the stuff that
you know guys like us spend most of our
day talking about are you shocked to see
how
rapidly they've crumbled or is this is
this just the last gasp of air like
what's happening right now
well i think trump took took the last
bit of credibility out of the system
but all he did was reveal what the
system was
i don't i don't think that he changed it
as much as he
you know revealed it and we can see it
so who knows
how corrupt the news used to be i mean i
used to hear his stories back in
kennedy's day
of the you know kennedy would go out in
the yacht and take the uh
take the new york times or the other top
reporters with them
and did he get good coverage of course
he did
of course he did so you know things are
different
but i don't know if they're more corrupt
i think we just might be a little more
aware of it
and and the thing that trump did is he
just completely just said
i think i'll just say whatever i want to
say as long as it leads me in you know a
productive
way that's good for the country didn't
worry about the facts
and it didn't hurt him at all he became
president doing that
when everybody was saying well you can't
be president if you keep saying things
that the fact checkers don't agree with
and then he did and he proved that it
didn't matter that much so didn't worry
about the facts when
when people criticize you or they
criticize me
or some of the other people that are
just walking around not even that are
necessarily rah-rah trump people but
just don't suffer from trump derangement
syndrome
that's the thing the facts the facts the
facts the facts how do you i've heard
you explain it a little bit but but how
do you explain his
sort of loose relationship with the
facts
well i call it directionally accurate
so if trump says something like well
there were 40 000 people at my rally
but the real number was 25 000 it's kind
of the same
right it doesn't change how you think
about it a lot of people came to the
rally
how much should it have been i don't
know if he says
the economy is the best economy we've
ever had
but it's only the best one in the last
40 years
does that help us or does it hurt us
well it helps us because
the economy is a as a psychology engine
as i like to say
and if you think it's doing well you
invest you buy you have confidence
and then it does well so he has the
ability to
use hyperbole in a little bit of
exaggeration
to make things work better than they
would have worked without it
which is completely different than a
flat out lie like let's say
the fine people hoax that's nothing but
a divisive lie
that's a bad you know missing the fact
checking
that that's as bad as you can get but if
you're if you're just talking something
up that needs to be talked up that's
fine
yeah i i actually wasn't going to bring
this up but let's just do it real quick
before we get to your community
the very fine people hoax you were one
of the first people at least like
sort of mainstreamish people
or someone with some cred let's say that
was calling out the very fine people
hoax
and and pointing out that before
he said very fine people on both sides
which he meant about the debate
the monument argument in and of itself
that really he had condemned the white
nationalists in the kkk the sentence
before
biden has said that this is the reason
he's running for president
yet the media doesn't call him out on it
does does anything shock you at this
point
i i really don't understand if the media
doesn't know it's a lie
because they've been reporting it as
true for so long and they all believed
that they saw it
they saw it with their own eyes heard it
with their own ears now what they saw
and heard was the edited bar
right where they take they take out the
sentence where he clarified
that he totally wasn't talking about
those people yeah in the clear and clear
as possible words they just leave that
out
and that is misleading so uh the the
fact that the media does that is still
puzzling to me because i can't tell how
intentional it is or if they're really
just fooled by their own propaganda
it's hard to tell it's kind of i always
think it's like they've gone so deep
with it and repeated it so many times
that it would be just
too it would like shatter their world
basically if they had to admit that it
wasn't true it's something like that
yeah that's why trump basically could
win the election
just by uh bringing that up at a at a
debate
and just you know just stop the show
bring that up and say look here's the
deal people
go look up the transcript see for
yourself if they've been lying about the
central theme of the campaign i won't
even tell you what i think
just go look at the transcript get back
to me that'd be the end of
that can you imagine that during a
debate if he just literally said i'm
actually not even gonna i have two
minutes i'm not gonna talk for the next
minute and a half google it right now
that would actually
it would crack the internet google find
people hoax those three words and you're
you'll get all you want there you go all
right scott let's let's talk about your
locals community because you you were
one of the first people
that we brought on board you you were on
patreon before
and i kind of was like you know i think
we got a better option for you we took a
couple meetings you jumped on board
can you just tell me a little bit about
what your experience has been like and
and why you think what you're doing over
there is working because it really is
working
you've got a very vibrant community yeah
it's it's far exceeded my
my expectations it's way better than i
thought
and uh the problem i was having with the
other social media
from you know youtube and twitter is
that i couldn't control
what anybody saw because twitter could
shadow ban me youtube could demonetize
me
and it looked like one wrong move and i
would just be out of business
so here i am putting tons of work into
something that i have no control over
they can just
snap a finger and i'm out of business so
i thought wouldn't be good to have
we have one place where there's you know
only subscribers they want to be there
there are basically no trolls because
trolls don't want to
subscribe to something to just complain
so it ends up being this happy place
where you don't get all the nastiness of
the other platforms and i can't be
canceled
it's sort of perfect and and monetarily
it's it's been
you know well like i said it exceeded my
expectations uh almost embarrassing yeah
do you think that the future of the
internet
is subscription based as opposed to ad
based or
or in effect that we the free people are
the product
well if i speak for myself i can't
handle ads anymore
not not any kind of ads i can't watch
regular tv
i just can't watch anything with an ad
you know so even on
youtube i'll pay the subscription uh so
i don't have to watch the ads
so i i can't see other people being that
different i think
uh social media has has shortened our
collective attention spans
so sitting there for like a five minutes
of ads or even one minute
of advertising seems it just seems
impossible now
where in the old days you thought well
it's just amazing right
but now a minute seems like a lot i mean
a minute man when i'm watching youtube
and there's a seven
second unskippable ad it's like i'm
pressing that
roku i'm pressing that button over and
over and over
trying to trying to buy back a second of
my life
yeah i'm trying to start a hobby i'm
like seven seconds what can i
what can i do in seven seconds so one of
the things that i think is is
interesting about what you've done with
your community is
you're putting edgier content there
stuff that
either you kind of want to test out with
your own people or that you think maybe
is going to bring you more flack from
from the normies
what was the idea behind that
yeah there's some types of content that
if you put it out in the general public
it just attracts trolls but if i'm in my
subscription community it's all it's
only people who want to be there
so people you know they make comment
that they
disagree with it but it'll be a polite
disagreement
so there's lots of stuff that i just
wouldn't bother putting on the regular
internet
because i just don't want to you know
deal with the blowback but
on locals as i often say to them i go
don't spread this
outside of locals you know not like they
they could if they wanted to but
but i asked them to and they don't
weirdly i mean that's that's amazing too
imag imagine thousands of people and i
say this would really get me in trouble
don't put this on the internet and they
don't
they don't now none of it would kill me
so i'm not going to put anything there
that's going to take me down to
it completely but i really appreciate
the fact that they they actually keep it
online yes
can you talk a little bit just about the
the community side of it and what kind
of interactions you're having with
people there because
you know like everybody else that i'm
talking to this week and myself included
you know it's like we can get into it
with the with the trolls and all the
haters and all of that stuff but you
said they're not even they're not even
there so you're getting some actual
human communication
yeah the part of what i didn't expect is
that the
uh the other community people who just
are paying money to follow me
i didn't understand how much content
they would be posting themselves
and at first when i saw other people
posting to be honest my first impression
was
hey you know i'm the one who should be
posting
right right you know how about a little
bit more about me huh
huh and then i started looking at their
posts and i was like that's pretty good
and then see another one's like huh i
didn't see that
on twitter that's very interesting so
they end up
curating all these things that since
they they know i'm
you know the sort of leader of the
community
they assume other people in the
community would like what i would like
and then
they end up guessing really well what i
would be interested in so it's
fascinating that way
then there are a lot of direct messages
people pay a little bit more to direct
message me
and i try to answer all of those uh if i
can yeah
how different do you think the
internet's gonna look in in five or ten
years do you think we're really like i'm
starting to feel like we're
really at the end of this version of the
internet that in a certain way this
election almost feels like the end of
everything the debates feel like
the end of the debates i feel like we've
we've taken facebook and twitter
we've taken all of these things to their
end conclusion and that the internet of
2024
2025 is going to be way way different
than what we're looking at right now
well i've argued that artificial
intelligence has already taken over
the world it's just not exactly the way
we thought it would be it's not in a
robot body
it doesn't talk to us but the the
algorithms
of the social media platforms they
decide what you see
and they decide based on a simple rule
of what's going to make the most money
and
nobody goes to jail you know just a few
other considerations
and as long as that algorithm is going
toward that that one
outcome it's going to cause people to be
at each other's necks
so a lot of the the the fighting and the
the conflict and the divisiveness
comes from math it comes from the the
algorithms
it's not people deciding that we should
fight it's the machine
the machine decided that we're going to
fight and the machine decided
that i'm going to see something that's
going to make my hair catch on fire
and then i go over to locals there's no
algorithm
there's just people doing what they want
to do with the people they want to do it
with
and suddenly i feel like it's human is
human contact again
it's like real people but i think ai is
literally
i don't mean this in a figurative you
know analogy kind of way
i think it's behind us the takeover i
don't think it's
in front of us the game is fixed and and
we keep playing anyway
all right scott give me give me a
prediction for the election have you
made an official prediction yet
well i i've been saying that uh trump
would win from the start he's
he's uh sucking air in the polls but uh
i'm going to stick with my prediction
that the polls are inaccurate and people
are lying to those pollsters
because it's funny it's funny
i i asked on twitter a little twitter
poll have any of you
actually lied to the pollsters about
your support for trump
hundreds of people said yes and they
weren't saying
we might lie or we we think we'll do it
in the future
they said we have this year
yeah well what i thought i saw today as
we're taping this we're holding it for a
few days but i saw an article
that was from four years ago today and
it said it had it the average of the
hiller of the polls were hillary up by
14 points and hillary obviously lost so
right now when they show you okay
biden's up by maybe four points it's
like
guys deja vu all over again i mean come
on
it could be but you know the the one
thing that you can count on with 2020
is we're not done we're not done
you know it's not like we're going to
wait nothing's going to happen between
now and election day
there's a lot that's going to happen
between them and so anything could
happen
ain't it the truth all right like a
professional pimp out your locals so we
can send people over there and
they can see all that tolerance and
decency
yes it's scott adams.locals.com did i
get that right
you did that's what i have right here
very impressive scott adams
you are a man of persuasion thanks for
having me all right thanks my friend
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell